but I could see you having like a spot
one day in Mexico that you go to and
enjoy instead of going to Jamaica all
the time he thinks it's Puerto Rico I
could yeah you could tell people is
Puerto Rico but I could see you having
like a nice spot in Mexico can't do
Mexico really why
not I the only reason I like to travel
is to eat good food interesting and
Mexican food is just like the best
Mexican food is in America and is that
true though kind of maybe I agree with
you like San Diego and San Antonio yeah
dude the best street tacos I've ever had
in my entire life San Diego incredible
yeah and the you I got sick in Mexico
twice I've been in Mexico and I got sick
both
times interesting eating [__]
whatever or eating the I is it because
the meat is just not a good quality or
the water I think it's the water dude I
think whatever it is and I think you got
to be used to the bacteria and [__] in
the water I I don't know dude I just
just seems kind of [__] low rent to
me yeah well there's that was was a
suggestion but you're right you're right
they're monsters I have I've moved on
from Jamaica though I mean I still go to
Jamaica where is the new
spot maybe Costa Rica interesting Costa
Rica is a [__] interesting Nick have you
been to Costa Rica no I've only been to
Puerto Rico but I Puerto Rico sucks no
Puerto Rico is awesome I think Puerto
Rico is like the perfect you know it's
close right you can go to Puerto Rico
for a [__] weekend and you're not
going to feel like oh there's all this
extra stuff I could have done right you
got it no you no extra day and you get
it all you go to the beach you go
there's like there's three blocks of
downtown Old San Juan that you can look
at and then that's it there's nothing
else there there's [__] fighting and
like maybe like they have this like
bootle jungle that you can go to what's
good about Puerto Rico rainforest well
it's funny because fake yeah well I
guess they tell you they're like Puerto
Rico is like a natural Island so it
doesn't have any like big like animals
or florana or whatever but I'm like is
that how islands work I felt is in the
Galapagos Islands don't they have like
the biggest turtles in the world huge
iguanas yeah I think Puerto Rico just
kind of sucks they have shitty animals
they shitty animals the whole thing is
like this frog and you go into the
jungle Koke yeah the Koke and they they
you go into the jungle and the whole
time the tour gu is talking about like
they're building up this frog that's on
all their branding yeah and um this how
much it sucks D this little [__] tree
frog frog and and we get to the end of
the uh the walking tour in the jungle
and the tour gu's like um okay so um and
now we'll show you the Frog and there's
like a tree stump that's open they're
like we have to be quiet so we don't
disturb it and this lady looks into the
tree stump and then she's like okay it's
not he's not
here there's no the end yeah it was all
leaves it was basically yeah we saw a
different type of leaves well half of
Puerto Rico is that um it's I forget
what it is it's either St reges the
Dorado is it four cities and state reges
they have like this this like
development for people that want to pay
4% tax rate so Logan Paul Jake Paul
Peter Schiff that guy who's like The
Economist who's all the people that
don't want to pay federal taxes in the
US yeah they pay like
4% uh yeah the richz Carlton Reserve
it's just a bunch of rich people that go
like they pay 4% taxes there was also
like uh Bitcoin guys trying to turn
Puerto Ric that main guy Brock uh what's
his name the one that like go after you
if you Lesnar no no UFC guy right no
Brock Pearson or something he was in
like Mighty Ducks he was a child actor I
can't remember the story but him Brock
Pierce Brock Pierce he's a child actor
he I think he was in Mighty Ducks I
can't remember but he
was got caught up in this scheme in like
99 2000 with this guy who was uh like a
pedophile he was in Mighty Ducks yeah so
he was he he got caught up in the scheme
with this other it was him and two other
guys but one main guy was like he ran a
production company that I Brian Singer
invested in oh that uh would like
convince young boys to they did like
real world with 12-year-old boys but
then they were like raping the kids and
making child pornography and the one guy
got caught but Brock Pierce like I guess
kind of skated so on Twitter like then
Brock Pierce that was his story he was
in Mighty Ducks and then he got caught
up in this pedophilia thing is this kind
of is there proof to this or is
com no no no this is this is like want
know I just want to know exactly what
this is like this is like pre Pizza gate
stuff okay this was back like uh like
Hollywood is fil is this like the that
that open secret documentary yes yeah I
think this this is part of that's in
there but Den Deen yeah yeah yeah this I
get this G anier yes right yeah yeah
anier and then uh Gary Goddard maybe
Gary Goddard maybe sort of was there was
a guy named like it wasn't Mark David
Chapman but he had a name like that that
he was re Mark Rector Mark davidor Mark
David reor Mark David reor your brain
still works yeah dude I saw this
documentary I couldn't remember the name
of Argentina yesterday I kept saying
argentin Yeah I don't remember that
stuff but white pedophiles I remember
damn how did you pull the Mark David
record CU that's in the there's a whole
documentary when was the last an Open
Secret when was the last time you saw
Open Secret I don't know seven years it
whenever came out well that's what I
mean you remember a name from that who's
the agent Mark
Weiss which agent there was agent that
was like that's the one that's mainly
featured in there that I don't know but
I know that documentary came out it was
ignored everyone in Hollywood ignored it
but it was damning it was incredibly
damning it was a kid sitting in a
Drive-Thru of like delaco calling these
guys going why did you rape me and they
were like I'm sorry I was to die it was
crazy well literally he's like remember
when you rate me and they're like hey
come on stop you know we had fun too or
whatever and he's like sitting in a
Drive-Thru yeah no the documentary is
insane but on that when that came out
people would go after Brock Pierce who
had reinvented himself as a Bitcoin guy
yeah and he he's like somebody me and
Nick should give the tours of Puerto
Rico you just hear this there a bunch of
people sitting they're like [__] the
Frog we're like it's pedophiles it's
Bitcoin well Brock Pierce was offering
like like uh like $50,000 bounties to
anybody that could like unmask whoever
was calling him a pedophile on Twitter
interesting which means if he's paying
that much to get the information he's
paying that much to have this person
[__] killed also so he's got a lot of
Bitcoin he was like an early he bought
on the dip that's what you're saying
well well it but that's the thing is cuz
he's like the like the whole point when
Bitcoin started people were like oh this
is for pedophiles and drug addicts right
and then [__] so pedopiles and drug
addicts were like I guess dark dark web
money on the dark was it all dark web
originally and it's well that was the
that was the the the thought that was
the the use case for it was buying drugs
or child pornography you want to get
someone killed oh I want to get hire a
hit man and kill my wife so the worst in
Bitcoin in Bitcoin the worst kinds of
people you can imagine yeah somebody
trying to kill their wife for a
pedophile those were the de facto early
retail investors the early adapters and
then there had to have been somebody
that a lot of them there's a now a a
whole world of secret millionaire
pedophiles who couldn't figure out how
to use Silk Road who bought Bitcoin to
buy child pornography than couldn't
figure out how to use the tour browser
and now they' found the thumb drive and
they all live they're like oh literally
they all moved there're all in Puerto
Rico staring at that fraud going I wish
you were a kid yeah right they're like I
don't want to they're like I you know I
don't want to pay taxes on this you know
I just I bought this [__] years ago so I
love the idea of being a pedophile you
have the Bitcoin and you can't use the
browser you're just like and you can't
call TCH support well tour is kind of
hard to use I imagine yeah but I mean
it's like that's the idea that you can't
just call someone over and go hey
there's no Geek Squad Amazon customer
support right how are you doing Mr
Brock yeah I'm good listen I'm a
pedophile and I I figured out how to buy
the Bitcoin but how do I use the tour
browser to purchase child pornography
yeah oh Mr Brock okay I'm sorry you're
having a trouble with this Mr BR we want
to thank you again for being Amazon
Prime
subscriber and happy holidays to
you we will look into that those guys
are the best yeah it's so I was I I was
saying that like somewhat recently but
remember how mad and I don't think it's
that like xenophobia has went away
remember how [__] irrationally mad
people were at the Indian like customer
service department no anybody who
doesn't speak English at all like I get
I get furious well maybe you're bad like
no because in my mind I'm going like why
would you why would you put this person
on the phone this is the only thing they
have to do it's like a prank well this
is my point it is putting them in the
line of fire sometimes this is my point
though but the Indians are very friendly
the Indians everyone get mad at the
Indians but now nobody complains about
it now that it's the Filipinos oh yeah
the Indians are much better no the
Indians are much worse wait a minute
than the Filipinos nobody complains
about the Filipinos they're so much
better dude if I I call if I call any
customer service and they hear an accent
I hang up immediately and I call right
back and try to get a wiper what makes
the Philippine and by the way this is
off YouTube ready so go watch Nick
special but what makes the
so much better than the Indians
literally just calling you Mr or M your
first name then it makes you feel like
Donald Duck or Mickey Mouse and then you
know it's like it's so disarming okay
you know I just I I I think the Indians
have gotten better yeah in in the time
that they've done this they were really
terrible like they'd be like hello my
name is Josh but now they've gotten I
feel like better and they're more well
yeah I feel like they lie about their
names a little L they to F that's W
culture that's one of the positive
benefits Indian customer service people
no longer have to lie about their names
is that true did we did we start already
by the way yeah we've been doing this
for 20 minutes oh wow Nick just does
real good bits in life yeah what do you
think we're all enjoying each other's
company for no reason I thought we
talking about Puerto Rico with no ad
revenue and no money I thought sitting
here talking about I thought' be like
and we're start you we we all know who
everyone knows who everyone is we'll
we'll introduce everybody but we haven't
been here before right that new studio
it's in studio in New York nice it is
nice yeah it's in a building with other
it's a Wei workor or it was a Wei work
and it's people that rent space Shady
guys and gals and they just let you rent
it monthly they let you you sign a lease
but the people out there some of them
are working like a what's a phone booth
I know I saw that I was saying to him
it's like old timey reporter yeah
they're in like a phone boo like hey
yeah I don't know what's going get this
one on the wire pal right right just
being the guy who's like starting a
business and you just
rent yeah it's like a tiny little I
don't know what it is but there's people
out here they have no they're not part
of I think a company they're just Rogue
well they're they're entrepreneurs
they're
startups they're entrepreneurs and
they're like dude you know what I I want
to instead of working from at home I
want to go to an office every day I work
by the Freedom Tower yes they want to
they want to be inspired I kind of
admire it a little bit oh you
would AB abolutely would and I think
that some of them are doing good I guess
but every now and then you'll see like
an old woman in one of those weird
things like she's closed off in like
that phone booth and it's just piled up
with papers and weird like I don't know
what the hell she's doing I think that's
menopause I think that's that's that's
change of life yeah I think that's what
happens to every woman I help my buddy
start a company years ago that was out
of like a we work type space very
similar same was Brock Pierce Sunshine
Suites in the uh the East Village and
the whole company was this is when
social media was just starting um that's
just starting but like Myspace was still
around Facebook was around obviously but
the whole business plan was we were
going to sell social media marketing
packages to businesses um we go business
to business it was just a phone call we
like yeah well you know we'll run all
your social medias we'll link them all
together we had no idea how to use
social media like I didn't even know how
to [__] make a a a Twitter profile at
that time right and we just [__]
called people up and just ripped them
off and that was it and we started a
company and but did you when you did you
try to once the people trusted you with
marketing of their business did you even
try because that could have been by the
way that could have been a great
business oh yeah yeah that's that's
basically SEO and like like social media
consult like that's by the way that's
all Gary Vagner Chuck does and that
guy's worth a lot of money yeah but we
had no idea like we had no idea what we
were doing we had a guy named Merck I
remember this [__] intern we had an
unpaid intern from NYU that we made do
all of the like accounts like it was
like this [__] autistic kid with
pimples terrible skin he had no [__]
clue what he was doing dude and we just
ripped people off for like two or three
years interesting it was great and that
was what was it called again I
analyst.com did can we still can we go
to it I might be destroying his company
right now I analyst.com let's see if
it's still around is it still a thing it
must be I an est.com
oh wow we are the
2% there's a lot of lawsuit coming from
this show H we got a lot we got Brock
Pierce and then we got the people at I
anal us that's kind producers be like
we're being sued by three different
people that's why I didn't think we
started because yeah Brock Pierce does
threaten people well I didn't know but
it's content yeah I think they figured
it out by the way yeah no it looks great
they I mean look here's the deal you
came up a big part of it a big part of
the marketing was simply showing a
graphic with like a little bunch of like
stick people and then with like arrows
pointing to your business sck people
more stick people that pointed to to
YouTube and that that Arrow pointed back
to your business yes no that's the it's
the chart was the primary yeah that was
huge you you started out as an
entrepreneur in this selling tickets in
Time Square yeah and you watched the
entire social media thing happen
yeah there yeah nobody was using social
media Dane Cook was I want make a
documentary by the way I very much want
to make a documentary about you okay and
like because that starting out as you
sold Comedy Club tickets and then like
the main guy was Steve hoffet that's he
I don't know if he would agree to do it
but I'd of course rather make a
documentary about Steve Hof St Steve
hoffet I feel I feel I feel worse for
than any well he was the original
Heckler Guy video I
he invented the entire business model
now he invented 20 years ago it's
ironically he's like the most
influential guy in comedy because it all
stinks at first every Trend in comedy
sucks yeah before it gets cool like
producing your own comedy shows when I
started was like whack like you were
like you were considered a [__] comic
who had to produce your own shows let's
see how many views he I guess he has a
new special let's see how many views
this
has 235 K 235k and when did it come out
uh a year ago okay the most influential
man in com he invented this he invented
the like self-produced self-promotion
yes right heckers planning planning
hecklers is just so there's just you saw
it happen and we all went oh he's
planning hecklers we know how real
hecklers are and there's no nobody has
50 [__] hecklers in a row right um
well that's but remember how because
people used to mock it they'd be like
comedian destroys heckers yeah and then
something changed I guess it was Tik
Tock is that the Tik Tok audience was
more amenable to the to the right and
now and now like you know I mean this
has got to it's like he's got to be
going crazy well he's got 800,000
subscribers on YouTube he's doing pretty
well he's doing a lot better than I
thought do I remember I did a a contest
at his Club in laughing devil yeah it
was the uh laughing devil comedy club
laughing devil comedy club yeah right
that was one in Queens the stand ended
up buying stand bought it stand he was
ahead of the curve in terms of like
putting out stuff MH social media on on
sites like YouTube and like way before
any D he was but he was like he just was
Shameless with it I remember I did his
contest he was like it was essentially a
bringer contest you like bring friends
but you didn't have to you don't have to
bring friends but it'd be good if you
did so I showed up I didn't bring any
friends and it's like me and five other
Comics like these are like just brand
brand new Comics I'm maybe three or four
years into comedy and then uh I ended up
I won the the competition it was an
audience vote and the other people
friends still voted for me cuz everyone
was so green um and then then and that
was to be passed at the club and then I
was like cool can I start putting it a
veils he was like you're now on to the
next round of the competition and he
wanted me to come in the next week to do
another competition I was like all right
[__] this no back when mypace was around
it's funny Myspace had they had a
MySpace comedy page you could convert
your profile to a MySpace comedian page
and it was him and and Giannis too I
feel like was very big on there yeah
perhaps yeah those guys you would see
him they were just friends with
everybody right Steve would add anybody
with like a comedian page or just like
add as many the whole business is full
of people who like dipped their toe into
something and then it was before there
was money in it or it was before it was
the thing to do well that's had they
just stayed with it they would be huge
but he he did stay with it well yeah but
he come on we mean like like for example
Giannis had Giannis stayed on YouTube
like then he kind of left that and he
started doing like the half hour and all
the [__] you thought you should do yeah
but
like that's the story of a lot of people
in the business that were like they were
there for a minute and then they it's
all it's all Peaks and Valley so you
watch all like Giannis had moments where
he was [__] up here and then it goes
down now he seems to be killing it right
now Chris D look at Chris D's career
dude he was like on Guy Code Girl Code
like things were [__] looking great
and then he [__] linked up with
Yannis and gas digital and did up it was
[__] [__] why would he do any of
that stuff and then he had a little bit
of a dip and now Chris is a [__]
celebrity like you know so it's it is up
and
down that's what I'm telling myself no
it is I'm trying to convince myself go
yeah we're both we're both down right
now that's not true we'll see you just
Lou I've only I've told you the only
thing you have to do is fire every
person that you see when you walk into
your Institution you have to fire if if
it's like a video game if they're even
in your ey line you have to fire them
fired get out fired get out yeah that's
all you have to do and hire a team of
Filipinos maybe or Indians by the way
why have you not outsourced this is a
great why have you not outsourced a lot
of the job to
Filipinos uh a lot of it a lot of it's
going to go to AI Mr hello Mr Zach hello
Zach I have brought you your Wendy's Mr
Zach we have ordered pizza we have your
advertisement for
crom here is your crom
read how is the uh the for for a second
Nick M's new special is out by the way
we we'll do this in the beginning of the
show oh okay we'll put this in the
beginning oh all right yeah L Comas and
Nick mulliner with us Nick has a new
special out on YouTube right now and
Lewis has a special out on YouTu
actually it'll be on the Adam Friedland
show channel I think this is defunct so
Nick Mullen special is out on the Adam
Friedland show channel we're just going
to try and consolidate and see if as you
should as well everything we need
something to work and so lisis Gomez has
a special that's on J Gomez Louis J
Gomez has a special this also hold you
back making people do that it's just if
I didn't know you now I hate you you do
it on purpose no it's just it's it's
there's no other Lis Gomez by the way
there is is there I think who there must
be there's the guy from Wednesday who's
this
genuine tag me sometimes he's a genuine
celebrity people tag me sometimes
thinking they're tagging Luis Guzman
yeah well he's a leg Happ the other day
yeah no Luis Guzman is a legend oh look
at that um L Gomez has L J Gomez has a
special on where gas digital.com no no
it's on YouTube it's on YouTube yeah
yeah it's all on YouTube all those half
hours are on
YouTube but Nick's comedy
is on the Adam freedland Adam Friedland
show channel it's called Year of the
Dragon Year of the Dragon Year of the
Dragon so uh you know I would look hey I
would love it if you could please like
comment subscribe and share because this
is all just a game and we're all trying
to be Steve hofstead so even if disagree
even if you [__] hate it look no I
don't maybe every other people do I
didn't want to do a special but there's
a a lot of money it's very funny I've
seen it you should watch it there's a
lot of there's a lot of money to be made
right now in stand up stand you got to
get you got to get to the theater level
you got to get I don't know what clubs
pay a lot of money too here's the other
thing too about a year and a half ago I
had like an eight pack and I will give
those pictures if you want to show it's
a I don't know I think you need women to
come to shows that's a big help yeah I'm
getting more of them but it's still not
the majority yeah well that's the thing
anybody that's doing real well I feel
like they they got 50% they tapped into
the girl ta into chicks they've tapped
into the girl Market somehow and I feel
that women can't hate you look at my
[__] Wheels Turner I was like wow
that the opposite of my strategy and
they I would say that they are sort of
my they not natural enemy but in the way
that you can't have like here's the
thing you can't have you can't have two
old cats in a small apartment the people
that are coming to your Shou it's it's
one person buying one ticket think about
this right no no I know this women
travel in packs dude it's infuriating
every time I look at in my crowd cuz my
fans are [__] losers I look at and
it's just a bunch of single and thank
you everyone for being part of our
journey it's a bunch of single
individual dudes that that they're
wearing big [__] clothes that are too
big for them they're all [__] dressed
like big Jay and none of them have any
[__] friends and then I look out I'm
like I'm surprised I even got to 60%
capacity I got to be honest with you
right because it's one person buy one
ticket with their mother's we should
make those guys buy more than one ticket
half of them are wearing a [__] like
17 XL Gilden hoodie yeah and so they
don't they take up the entire table as
it this is what happens before L this
about about three days if Southwest
Airlines can do it the comedy clubs can
do it before three days before Lewis's
show this is what happens in any house
someone the basement door opens and a
guy goes I'll give you the
cash no they they only take cards I'll
give you the cash it's not a
show it's not going to inspire me to do
anything bad it's comedy I say it to my
crowd all the time I was like just get
friends please I can start selling shows
out if you just have a friend right yeah
yeah I listen women travel in packs yeah
women talk to other women about this
stuff what do I have to do do I have to
watch The
Bachelor whole Nick it's whole thing
it's not just ABS you know what it is
you have to relate it's not even ABS no
it's like you have to like be cute
selling Sunset those types of shows that
being in shape has never done I talk
about selling Sunset but I relate it to
Israel and Hamas now that's not that
doesn't cuz I said the hottest real
estate show right now is the Hamas War
right it's even hotter than selling
Sunset that's a Brillion take are women
appreciating that I don't think so yeah
I I have a Hezbollah t-shirt I got and
you have no idea how hard it was to find
that oh it's so hard yeah now but some
women like my show and some women like
you know what we all do and they're
coming there's more of them coming now
than there have ever been before but
they you know that they're they're
[__] up they're damaged the girls that
are coming out to our show well they're
well how about this maybe it's not that
they're damaged maybe they have kind of
a little bit of the neural Pathways of a
male that maybe they're successful like
in that they're you know you think that
because I've seen some of the gals at my
shows and that's not what I think when I
see
them well I will say that it runs a
gamut I I'm surprised that the amount of
people that come to my shows that are
softspoken Hispanic guys yes that are
like yeah I've been uh I've been Ling
for like
years well you know what it is yeah you
know like like me and my friends we've
been since like high school right
because they're they don't have a
culture that's available to them yes
they do it's the audio installation
section of Best Buy right sure but you
come in and you fill that you fill that
in it's PlayStation 5 it's interesting
some Comics we know it's really racial
some Comics are supported by their
people I'm not supported by gay people
and you're not really supported by
Puerto Ricans which is what I like I
trick them I trick them though because
Latinos you trick the Latinos look edit
this point out Latinos are stupid okay
they're easily not editing that they're
easily Tri to my audience I will say I
will not stand for
this I'm not going to sit
here this this monster exuse this hate
speech you know I I get when you like
Latinos and blacks like just in the wild
like in the clubs come watch our
specials yeah they're on YouTube and uh
but I'm saying they they love me in the
wild they won't love if they if they
they believe the hoopla and the hype
they're not going to be into what I do
but if I just happen upon a black family
in a comedy club they're going to love
what I do now let me just right rewind
this if you happen upon black family in
a comedy son most Miss there looking for
a job black family in the comedy club it
happens they're going to love what you
do they're going to love what I do cuz
they got real problems dude they're not
going to be offended by all these no no
words dude they're [__] this guy's
[__] but by the way can we Market
your next tour like that black families
have real
problems come see LZ I'll say this I
don't think I don't think my stand Up's
offensive I think it's pretty like it's
not that any of us are offensive we're
not talking to women no the [__] I would
do on C toown is offensive but that
but that's that is I always felt that
that was more of a born out of a disdain
for comedy itself so it's like what if I
said this right not that I am saying
this right but it's like what if I how
lazy would it how funny would it be to
lazily say this the that doesn't make
any sense but it doesn't make a ton but
yeah the the that's the Brock Pierce
pedophilia thing it's more like what if
I was yeah right um but but no I get
what you're saying you're almost like
in a podcast sometimes you just say the
[__] lowest hanging fruit because
you're like well I shouldn't say the
lowest hanging fruit dating is where
it's at if you're a lot of women most
women that go out want to hear about the
mating ritual and if you're going to
talk about that that is going to excite
them this is from my very cursory study
of this now I don't discuss it I also
have a gay guy I can't discuss I cannot
discuss
men and women and what they do would you
start sleeping with women so that you
could have a new if I went a woman route
it would be and it could be very
successful it would be kind of a
CBS like you know it's me and my and my
wife and there's a Mexican family and
it's we're on a border and they move
next door and I'm like rough around the
edges it's not a bad idea it's like you
know if you could do like a a Chuck Lori
thing where you used to be gay and now
you're straight well that is could be
the sick I'm on CBS in like five years
that would be I'm an ex gay yeah guard
at the border
yeah and you know and then my wife is
always trying to get me to like see them
as people yeah and I have I see some of
them as people but I struggle with it
yeah but there's a great scene where
they make me Mexican food we all did I
ever tell you about I was on the border
one time when I saw a border patrol guy
wearing a kilt they allowed they let him
do that he had the rest of his uniform
on but he had a kilt on
underne that's amazing it's it's so
insulting they're clearly not taking it
seriously this is the problem can you
imagine you go you walk the border
patrol is just theater kids yeah yeah
yeah it wasn't like a bunch of them it
was one guy that had guy it was at
McDonald's yeah US law enforcement and
kils they're allowed to do that they
could just choose that I guess what is
the next iteration of what do you think
goes on here because you're a mind
you're in the
game you're see
right now you're seeing a lot of crowd
work like I just did a crowd work clip
in uh San Diego gets five million views
yeah it's just crazy people love that
interaction I honestly have no I don't
give a [__] I did the special because
you're supposed to hopefully people like
it people are going to love it hopefully
that the second that standup doesn't
make sense MoneyWise anymore I'm done of
course I'm [__] I'm done I believe
many of us feel that way and then I'll
I'll go back
to it makes no sense MoneyWise for me
talking people who agree with you it's
just a hobby what are you talking about
it's it's crazy too because like
everybody that's like quote unquote blow
I'll give you the cash I get paid Friday
the show is Friday that's why I can't
give you the money now I would have been
paid last week but I missed a day cuz I
was sick I would have made more money
helping put this set together than I
make doing stand up but that's also cuz
you're like touring in Europe you go to
like London and Europe yeah but these
are like little clubs these no I know
but you're I mean you're spending a lot
of money to get to the place oh yeah
there that's terrible idea but even even
CRA I see what you're doing me Dave
Smith Zack and Robbie burnson we brought
four people you bring a whole crew to
like Lima Peru like well whose idea is
what agent is cosigning this oh I'm
gonna kill
myself
um do do you think the crowd work stuff
holds on do you think these clips do you
think we live in this world forever no I
think it's a it's a fad to a certain
degree I think honestly standup is
really hot right now and all the
podcasters are touring right now and
doing standup and that's going to cool
off for a minute people discount like
how much of this is also just like the
pandemic prevented people from going out
and doing anything now people are out
yeah people came back then you get a
bump off Tik Tok which Tik tok's going
to be illegal in three months once you
think they're gonna they're shutting it
down I think they are I've always said
that now the Tik tok's gone after Israel
I mean yeah you could do anything you
want
but you could be on Tik Tok you could
throw as many paraplegic people in front
of the train as you want that that
that's all fine you can have a Tik Tok
honestly the the Osama bin lad that was
the funniest thing hilarious that the
people like oh everybody on Tik Tok
saying Osama Bin Laden's good now and
it's like two videos yeah it wasn't even
a huge thing it was not it was two
videos it was yeah it was one honestly
very funny video of like you know some
yeah black lady being like girl girl
have you read this letter he was right
oh my god did you know made some points
girl do you know about the muah
hadin
was that girl damn yeah the muah what
they've been talking about getting rid
of it uh for a long time they've been
talking about Good get rid of it get rid
of all sort by the way all of it I'm
kind of agreeing not not in the sense
that I I care about the bin lad letter
but I say get rid of it get rid of it we
were happier before we had social media
get rid of all of it no we weren't
happier I I don't know if we were Happ
I'm the exact I think well some people
were happy a lot of people might have
been happy I everyone D just in the
anxiety that people have for you were 20
years old you wer our entire career Happ
because of social our entire career is
this yeah you cannot roll it back I'm
just saying ban Tik Tok I don't have
followers me personally I would that's
my only I'm saying let's reset because
people have really blown past me on this
thing I didn't know what was going on
let's reset now and let's let's reset
I'm just saying reset so you just wipe
Clean Slate keep Tik Tok but dump every
everybody has to start at zero and we
all start over now and delete and you
get a six-month Head Start well it's not
the worst idea but no I think we delete
Tik Tok and go this one's no good
because it's the Chinese or whatever
it's trying to kill whatever you should
do whatever is because I have like no F
I've got what 60,000 followers let's
delete this now this is bad well I
haven't tried but this is embarrassing
now let's delete this because of the
Hamas in the Chinese yeah
it's just like which one are you the
best at then YouTube Hamas social media
I don't know pod what podcasting but
it's not social media Instagram is the
one that I think is best podc podcasting
is social media so then that one that's
the one I'm good at yeah and Instagram
I'm okay at because I get the I know how
to do the swipe up I wish I'm 38 you got
to realize we're all getting old yeah I
already I'm old we're old we're old so
I'm I'm 41 years old the reality is
these things don't make as much sense
like I don't and I think it shouldn't
they don't make as much sense to me as
they did back in you know well they it
got weird and almost like abstract for a
minute remember there was like that uh
that 8sec one where you can only do like
8sec videos that was like aine yeah that
was there was no there was no use for it
there was no purpose it was just people
became stars on that and listen then it
shut down and they some of them
committed suicide yeah they disappear
genuinely they disappear they kill
themselves on a loop we know
we know people that were like that was
their whole career yeah and then they
just I mean
gone sometimes like but that's show
business that's show business has always
been that that's true it's like [__]
literally you get your 15 minutes of
fame and then you get you know sexually
molested by a producer and then it ends
and then the government comes and says
oh that $20 million you made we're
taking 13 of it and then uh you get
behind on your mortgage the bank takes
that back and now you're just a guy that
that was
molested right and then you kill
yourself and that's that's what being a
comedian has always been that's what it
should have been the goal and that's
when it was actually good that's when
remember when the goal was to simply
just be alone on the road making $1,500
a weekend yeah that was it yeah that was
the top of the mountain yeah it's true
yeah no this didn't exist I remember
thinking I remember when I started
comedy being like oh dude if I could
just do the I could just get funny the
funny bone
yeah if I can make $50,000 a year doing
like the first thing you do is take a
mega bus to like an Albany Funny Bone
and you stay overnight like a dump and
you feel great yeah you feel amaz it's
actually the best feeling ever the first
time I stay in a Red Roof in actually
dude I think you were were you with me
was it did you do the strip club yeah
was that the first time dud I think that
was the first time you said had a Red
Roof in and I remember almost got into a
fight with the Indian guy beyond the
counter what Happ did they not have your
sweet I they they he's like Lou is like
I pre-reserved a sweet literally yes
they were like yeah we don't have your
reservation they didn't have there was
exposed [__]
like down from the ceil there they was
like a pardon our [__]
appearance and that sign was falling
apart no the whole the place was a mess
they had [__] they you know you go to
like a real shitty motel and they have
prices for all the things you can steal
that's right yeah and had on there it
was like the microwave right the like
picture frame
$125 CU people are just stealing
everything they're just warning you
don't [__] around here yeah don't steal
the [__] microwave dud just smelled
like mold the whole hallway dude and
yeah we [__] shower curtain you you
can take year was this this six seven
years ago at least no it was like
2014 isn't it good that all of our
friends have done well yeah well that's
thend how you define well yeah and
friends we're doing all of our because
some of our friends haven't but every
everybody that we know has like has is
not doing that varying degrees of he not
doing the Red Roof in better than better
than I thought it was come on that's not
true some people are not doing well they
are our friends I'm very happy I have
hair and so many of my friends have hair
and a lot of them don't have hair but
they wish they did have hair some of
them do and I tell them they about keeps
because keeps is about keeping the hair
that you have right now you get expert
care for hair loss from the comfort of
your home without ever visiting a
doctor's office all the treatment plans
are personalized to address your unique
needs if you are losing your hair and
you want to stop it dead in its tracks
keeps is an online subscription service
that makes it easy and more affordable
for men to treat their male pattern
boldness from the comfort of their own
home with keeps get clinically proven
treatments to address hair loss and
boost hair regrowth delivered right to
your door in discret packaging complete
an online consultation to get matched
with a treatment plan tailor to address
your hair loss concerns find a plan that
works for your schedule with the
flexibility of three 6 and 12mth
delivery options plus you can adjust
pause or cancel at any time it's easy
they've got over 4500 F store reviews
with impressive before and after photos
from real customers they deliver
treatments directly to your door it's
discreet it's non-branded packaging
you'll love it so hair law stops with
keeps for special offer to get started
go to keeps.com Tim Dillan or click the
link in the description that's
ks.com IMD l n
ks.com Mt l n yes but Tim dumps those
people he doesn't consider those people
friends no they're not it's not that
they're not my friends but it's just
like you know what do you want it's like
what do you want what do you what do you
talk to somebody about what do you do
what do you do what do you do for those
people you really can't that's you can't
do that's what I mean I love those
people but I what are you going to what
are you going to do it's not is there
not like there's not any kind of there's
not like it's there is some you can
after the fact take a look at success
and say these are the the factors that
led but that doesn't mean that you can
like just isolate those things and then
the the but even those that are horribly
yeah I would say that many of them are
doing better than they were I don't know
there's people I'm not I'm not going to
name names but there's there's Comics
that are extremely funny yeah and that
who haven't caught on yeah and but they
have exposure people know who they are
and they're good and like they should be
doing better than they are yeah and uh
for whatever reason it just doesn't like
it's like uh watching like a like a
airplane try to start
like you know what I will say that I
really appreciate about you you Shane
like from an outside perspective it's
from a brown person's perspective oh
we're gonna do that now brown person
perspective okay [__] listening I I
like the uh I like the fact that people
could no longer say that they're not
succeeding because they're white guys
that was a thing for a few years
dude I'm a white guy we're just not
getting booked and it's like that's just
not the case anymore they love white
guys again white guys are back in a
massive way in the industry Tom SAR Bert
[__] uh Matt re I think when the
white guy thing was happening that was
more like PE I heard that more with guys
going like I can't get a writing job and
that was true because they're telling me
their agents were telling them we need
to staff this with but it's funny
because it also like it it it it it
[__] over the people that I don't know
they were trying to I I I didn't feel
that um and I don't think like Kurt did
either because they would staff a room
and then they would have this is cfir by
the way it's not a glass of milk going I
feel like it's rude to say diversity
hires or whatever but you would have a
diverse writers room but then they would
hire a white guy and the white guy they
would hire would always be like a white
guy with darker sensibilities that would
say stuff that would be perceived as
offensive because that in of itself is a
type of diversity who wouldn't get hired
as the white guys that are like guys can
we just uh be a little nicer to women
you know those guys wouldn't get hired
right because it's like the guys who
secretly wanted to rape everyone in the
room yeah wouldn't get hired I mean
that's probably the reason I don't know
yeah can we just be a little kinder to
these ladies and do you need a ride home
mhm because I'm a rapist yeah um yeah
the UCB cat sweater yeah aggressive
messenger that's I would love to do a
little like movie about a charact I have
a character in my head that is one of
those guys cuz that was such an annoying
type of guy
10 years ago yes they were everywhere
Ultra feminist cat sweater wearing
rapist right exactly yeah and they
always had a name like Brandon Scott ER
one of the you know always had a name
Nam four first names yeah it was yes
yeah I'm David I'm David Brandon Scott
one of the one of the shortest and most
ill- fated podcasts of the boom was not
bastard radio it was a podcast called
rape dicks rap dicks it's called rape
dicks where Lou Gomez myself and I
believe Karen fian maybe were
investigating Open Mic rape claims
comedy rapes comedy
rapes and
employing uh our knowledge of the you
know and by the way we the most famous
rape probably or one of them but
probably the most famous rape we
investigated it and it got weird it
actually got cool mhm it was hilarious
it was uh we found
some very interesting things happening
and it didn't addend up remember that
remember how exciting it was it was the
girl rape right no that was one of the
other episodes that was where we
actually had her on that was hilarious
and she said that Casey Anthony thing is
still my favorite moment the the
highlight of that whole era in new it
was Aaron you know his name yeah yeah
yeah but the highlight of all of the
meos in New York comedy was when Ray
comp and uh margar
ree yeah margar Ree and Ray comp yeah
were canceling each other yeah they were
like I don't know like [__] I think
Mark touched Ray's tit and then Ray
grabbed Mark's penis and then they had
like a two-day battle on Facebook where
Ray's like what you touch you touched my
breast first who attacked me first I was
defending you touched my breast first
and then and then Marg I think start
Mark started to lose so he transitioned
uh oh was it that one of those perhaps I
don't know but there was another one of
those and that I think that's what
happens to you get an argument in a bank
and you start to lose you go I'm a woman
now that put an end to it there was no
more it was that one and the other one
where and this was the funniest one
because I remember this is back when I
was on Facebook I like woke up I go on
Facebook and I'm not I wasn't really
checked into I really kind of only ever
hung out at the stand so I was never
really fully integrated in the New York
standup scene and um that's why I saw
you I see on Facebook that someone's
saying just to let everyone know mo fafb
as a rapist yes and I was like I
remember this he ran that very woke
Brooklyn
comedy was that very woke comedy I was
like there's no way that that's a name
what was it called that thing he
ran Sesame Street yeah I was like a
[__] it was like the the [__] was
it the annoyance theater no it was like
it was something where it was like the
Brooklyn comedy Collective or like it
was like come to the comedy commune or
whatever yeah and then well then that
also turned into then the story came out
and he was like no I blacked out and you
raped me and then it was them it was him
and this woman arguing about who raped
who and it just turned it turned the
whole thing into like a laughing stock
and then nobody nobody was well we found
some weird [__] with the U with the
Glazer thing where we found some stuff
where it was like remember we found that
nonbinary person yeah dude in the mix
and it was like these two women and we
interviewed his roommate listen we we I
I completely forgot about that entire
thing actually it was really great I I
don't even know where you can find that
podcast don't is it a real ass podcast
is it on that feed it had to be doggy
that [__] was [__] wild and then it
the reason we stopped was cuz it
actually got dark it got dark and we
actually started uncovering [__] where
it was like we're talking like can you
tell me what happened so well so here's
the thing I feel left out there's a big
rape story you this guy was not really
right he was not a successful comic but
he was completely
thrown out of the scene because a claim
two women claimed that he drugged and
yeah drugged and raped them and me and
Lewis wanted to know more so we
interviewed his roommate now his
roommate said also too that that whole
thing blew up because when it initially
happened when the fire storm initially
started there was people cancel like
saying oh this guy's a rapist and it was
based on a screen cap of an anonymous
message from somebody who works at UCB
who said that somebody else said this
guy was a rapist right so it was like
and that's when meker got involved and
he was right to say we and I also I kind
was like I was like look you can't
[__] destroy a guy but then once we
started but there was not even details
it was just that he's a rapist as soon
as we started as soon as we spoke to two
people that knew him we were like this
is a dark individual yeah we're like
he's a dark individual but also I think
it was it was one of those situations
where I think everybody was
lying yeah that's what you realize when
you get to the depths of these
everybody's lying and then you start
going oh he is a rapist but he might not
have raped those people when they said
he did yeah cuz the roommate's telling
us the time the girl saying it happened
he never brought one girl home ever yeah
so I don't know what the hell then the
roommate was like but no no this guy
rapes but then the roommate's like but
he's also a
rapist it was
lit girl he was she was like well like
so's innocent she goes no he's a r or
something like wait a minute hold on it
got so complex we were on phones yeah in
like in a bar eating and like doing
actual research and this is before
what's that podcast that didn't we call
him yeah we did what was the podcast I
got huge with Adon sad who cial this is
the original one literally the original
serial and we called him and we're like
we we're investigating your rape claim
and he goes who is this went it's Louis
goz he thought it was a cop it's lisis
Gomez and Tim Dylan and were
investigating your rape and he's like
like
okay a [__] me the me too movement was
so huge for a [__] hot minute and
rape didn't stop or maybe it worked
maybe people stopped raping but I just
think it like anything else was a
[__] fad it's like crowd workor
videos they shut it down after the Tera
Reed thing that's where it ended what
like glob Tera Reed made claims against
Joe Biden and then they had the right
art there was articles wait Tara Reed
the the the no different Tara re okay no
she was a staffer she was a staffer in
the '90s she made claims against him and
then she ended up like uh like defecting
the Russia and so now people right
because he she was saying he okay now I
remember no so there was rape claims but
then when that happened this came up re
worked for Biden as a congressional a in
'92 and 93 and later later attended
Antioch University she l d d Reed
misrepresented herself and her life
experience on numerous okay so this is
all just she nothing ever happened when
this happened then there was there had
to be articles that were like uh well
believe all women doesn't actually mean
that's the thing once someone comes out
and goes at one of the Sacred cows they
go oh actually we didn't mean believe
all women also believe all women is the
craziest thing in the [__] world it's
psychotic the craziest person we all
know is a woman guarantee if you think
about the craziest person you've ever
met in your entire life it's a [__]
female guarantee I mean also the point
the the substance of the believe all
women doesn't mean like you know they're
incapable of lying in the same way that
black lives matter doesn't mean that
like white lives don't matter you know
it's like it's not that it's mainly
directed at the people who are supposed
to investigate these things like like
the police for example is it though but
because I don't think so because you
you'll see it it's still to this day it
might have started as that Nick but it
really became more of a cultural thing
social media I well that's where but
social media became life for everybody
this this proves that the level of
nuance you're demanding for a while
there that if a woman claims to have
been assaulted she's not lying was this
this proves that it never meant that
because because sure I don't believe it
because the people that were the most
diard supporters of it like obviously
held that Nuance in their heads because
something like this comes up and they're
like well I you know what I mean they
have no they have no problem with the
collateral damage when it's happening to
their enemies oh I mean but but also I
mean you know I don't know are people
really investigating this no you the
same people on the other side nobody's
investigating this right you get H
you're like oh yeah no he did it no
matter what cuz [__] Joe Biden
right on social media what it sort of
became was like you know somebody would
claim something like a girl I just saw
this happen recently uh another comic
got accused some [__] some girl posts
some very vague the thing that she posts
and people are just responding to it
hash believe all women I believe you I'm
so sorry this happened to you you're
like like just just a blind like a blind
accusation you can just do that and just
randomly people will just blindly follow
it that's kind of crazy I just love the
idea of like it was me guys I'm being
taken down the people are represented by
two equally important groups leis Gomez
and Tim Dyan rape dicks and we just have
to go back I'll bring it back right now
and and and just because here's the
thing there are answers to all of these
open mic comedy
rapes if you if you look hard enough I
know I think the answer is that it's not
any more prevalent in comedy than it is
anywhere else this building the the the
people who work here they deal with
sexual assault and they I've been raped
three times you loved it I walk it off
who cares it's not a big deal Tim walks
in the elevator backwards I try to get
raped um I had I had my anus and
genitals removed after seeing the Barbie
move that's not really something I have
to worry about that makes a lot of sense
I Caitlyn Jenner came to my friends
giving in Los Angeles really yeah that's
great you told me you were going to try
to get her to come to skankfest that
never happened she wasn't into it
did you really try I tried you said dude
I want to Tim called me up he's like
dude I want to break the internet that's
an insan I'm gonna
bring you Caitlyn Jenner Gary we Kim
Jong-il Kim Jong-il Eli
Roth Bobby Lee yeah Kim Jong Santino
yeah it was just some it was wacky just
a bunch of La idiots when are you coming
out there um I don't know yeah I gotta I
got to figure out a date figure it out
introduce me to [__] Caitlyn Jenner D
just hang out me you and Caitlyn Jenner
going out one night would be hilarious
amazing you'd be the best she Lov me
what does she do now you don't hear her
she was going off for a while she flies
her plane like a personal she has a
little plane that she flies in Malibu
and enjoys that's I don't understand why
you would do that well people like a
people are aviators what you want me to
tell you I don't know it's like begging
to get killed by the CIA I agree I would
not be in a plane like that but this is
what the woman wants to do yeah the very
natural woman what she wants to do who's
65 hey Tim get him my playing she walked
in and she goes I taught all my kids to
be punctual I was like you're very on
time she goes I told all my kids to be
punctual I'm like what a dad thing to
say I was like what a dad like I was
like what a stand up straight stand up
straight it's your vbl but she was
talking about how nobody's patriotic I
just talked about on Matt and Shane it
was a great you know I'm I'm a big fan
of her and I like what she I think
that's the next step in the evolution of
trans people like trans Republicans yeah
that's you need it you need it that's
when you know you have full equality
when PE when the kids on Twitter are
going [__] her she's a Nazi but with the
right pronoun she's a
Nazi yeah she's right here we go so
disappointing another biological male
stealing Podium slots medals and
financial opportunities from women in
sports this madness must end so she's
against uh
transitioning male to female
transitioning she's interesting because
nobody knows more about Athletics than
that woman yeah and transitioning I mean
transition is the authority on this
subject she's the authority on this
subject we no one but her we should
listen to no one but her she's a gold
Med he was a gold medalist and then she
became an expert on being a a trans uh
person why should anyone else matter in
this discussion and I love that she's
never cited that's also one of these
crazy arguments that people have like we
all logically go like oh well obviously
you know biolog obvious it's just so
obvious everyone agrees if you put
everyone in the world into a [__] lie
detector test they'd all go like all
right we all agree with that but it's
10% it's extremists who are nuts and
then their supporters aren't even real
but it's like it's it's almost like the
left's version of like gun nuts where
you're like like people that really want
their guns are like no dude no
regulations we don't give a [__] we want
[__] nothing the more guns the better
you're like well no that's crazy right
we agree that some people shouldn't have
guns
right you'd think right you would think
you know I don't know I agree with you I
don't I don't think everyone should have
a gun some people should some people
shouldn't Caitlyn Jenner should yeah she
should also be the head of the tobacco
Firearms all all the sports that like
women's sports that they there's been
like any controversy or all sports that
like who cares well because it's the
women like Oh shot put this is why we
don't shows the poor women shot Putters
well I agree with you but it's the women
that are trying to get a scholarship to
college with swimming or something and
it's also they started this journey
[__] 13 years ago before this was
even a thing but here's the deal they
invested their their time into becoming
a high level athlete and now it's being
taken college should be free anyway so
there's the well yeah but it's not so
it's we we could say maybe maybe you
make it you maybe even if College ISE
let's say you want to be an Olympian
uhhuh if you want to be Olympian in a
female thing you're going to be defeated
by just biological men but the what we
would want is to that see that one that
one makes the least sense to me how
because we're competing against other
countries that are going to have
biological men doing it too well no of
course they will we'll make we'll we try
to find the mo we we'll Force we have
all train we'll Force yes yes okay I see
well that's a strategy yeah I agree with
you I mean if yes if if we have an all
[__] female team
yeah and we're destroying everybody even
ones where it doesn't matter like darts
no it's just all [__] yeah
Marksmanship yeah yeah an all [__]
American Olympics isn't the worst idea
also technically men shouldn't have the
advantage in a game like darts but I
don't know I don't know the world dart
record but I guarantee you the best Dart
player in the world is a guy yeah I love
watch I love watch he's not thinking
about the eras tour
I mean of course he has the mental
capacity to handle just the board and
the thing yeah he's not like my sister
got fourth row how did she get fourth
row her husband's gay ttim could you get
me tickets to Taylor Swift for my we by
the way all three of us should we
because I know I'm I'm gonna guess I'm
safe for a fact that none of us have
seen that show no right should we all
just go to the erors tour let's go
because it's the one cultural thing that
we haven't exper well there's many of
them but that's the one glaring I think
she's mad at the Adam Friedland show so
oh right because of the mty Healey thing
yeah I get it well I believe I've said
she's a mediocre talent but she probably
doesn't know yeah I don't think it's her
birthday next week too oh great happy
birthday Taylor good for her do you hate
her I don't hate her I just feel like
I'm I miss it's Miss it's lost on me
she's the she's America sweetheart she's
the she's the girl you want wanted my
entertainers to be sweethearts that was
never something I wanted but I get it I
don't prr her and ounce of her success
yeah I just personally that that and you
just kind of nailed it that is lost on
me like Kelly rippo was always lost on
me Kelly ripo was always this person
Mario Lopez all of that stuff all of
these people who like Mario Lopez Mario
Lopez isn't a thing people like though
no it's not that there's nobody there's
no there's nobody nobody's a Mario Lopez
fan but everybody in America welcomes
Mario Lopez into their home he could be
on the Today's Show he can be on a
cooking show
you have no option just but I never
understood why like that t like Kathy
Lee I liked when she was with regious
cuz she was a drunk her husband was
cheating on her just hated her just
would scowl at her he actually liked her
he actually hated Kelly cuz Kelly was a
demon from hell yeah yeah who is but
Kelly was like I'm Mrs I'm the nice mom
but everyone she's a demon yeah so it's
weird I never that I just get very
suspect of people whose whole sales
pitch is like I'm nice and I love
everyone I love everyone and everyone
loves me yeah those are the most like
Sinister people that's like Ellen right
that's what happened with her oh yeah
she's like America
CIA no one's liked that most people are
just sort of Grouchy most of the well
that's what I trust no one's like the
way that these people are like yeah like
Taylor Swift is give me I'm GNA give you
a perfect example a girl died at her
concert in Brazil because it was hot
whatever it a heat stroke and Taylor swi
put out a thing which I get get why you
do this but but that thing get the
statement up Taylor Swift about the uh
I'm sorry my show was too spicy for you
she was basically I can't believe I'm
writing these words but it is with a
shattered heart listen to this I can't
believe I'm writing these words but it
is with a shattered heart that I say we
lost a fan earlier and then she said
something like I don't know much about
her but I knew she was beautiful it is
with a shattered
heart shattered heart I just there's
something about it to me that just it is
something doesn't yeah well her heart
was shattered cuz she got cheated on
right before right it doesn't pass to
smell test for me I don't know why I
can't articulate why something I feel
just doesn't it's I don't know it's
because you she's like describing a real
emotion in the fakest way possible it's
just it's it's just it's hypocrisy it's
everything it's everything that sucks
about celebrity right here's what tell
us with should have said people die in
this country all the time did she
handwrite this what is this this is the
the statement that she posted on like
her story this is the statement let's
read the whole statement because it's
insane she's like I I TR I'm writing
these words but it is with a shattered
heart that I say we lost a fan earlier
tonight before my show I can't even tell
you how devastated I am by this there's
very little information I have other
than the fact that she was so incredibly
beautiful and far too young I'm not
going to be able to speak about this
from stage because I feel overwhelmed by
grief when I even try to talk about it I
I want to say now I feel this loss
deeply and my broken heart goes out to
her family and friends this is the last
thing I ever thought would happen when
we decided to bring this tour to Brazil
also what is the what why is this in a a
handwritten font do you want just
understand something's wrong here well
this is a typed message that's been put
into a handwritten font is that her
actual um handwriting no that's no no no
I'm saying is this her actual thing or
did somebody else make this image you
know what I'm saying like a fan could
have made this and put it on a website
this is her thing oh it is from her
story yeah oh yeah that is a handwritten
font that's
psychotic something is odd
about I'm just saying well I'll tell you
why because something's odd no there was
that other concert with what's his name
uh Travis Travis Scott he didn't say
[__] I know he didn't care well people
got mad at him and that was good people
got mad at him for that so now was in
Houston the same weekend to skankfest
people shot
into his concert and he's like The Show
Must Go On he showed up the next week to
like Jersey like let's
go yeah you remember that uh back in the
day the great white concert where their
pyrotechnics lit the place on fire that
video is crazy have you seen it yeah
it's wild I watched a documentary on it
it's [__] the whole thing is nuts in
uh what was it Connecticut Rhode Island
Rhode Island yeah the uh Warwick Rhode
Island yeah great white they played a
show and the they had pyrotechnics
behind the stage and it was they they
didn't get a proof for pyrotechnics they
had like a pyro like they're they're
they're trying to relive like their
Glory Days from the 80s like a little
club like the size of the Irving Plaza
the whole building was a Tinder Box but
they only had like one point of ESS and
it was behind the merch table right so
[__] a 100 people got trapped in this
building and there was a guy recording
the show and he got out first and he
just kept recording as people were
burning the death inside the building
and you can hear them screaming the
whole time well a lot of people died of
smoke inhalation and being trampled to
neck don't be so morbid okay all right
well yeah smoke in
I'm just saying I want to see a little
toughness from Taylor Swift I want to
see a little life's not fair from her
yeah I want to see a little this is why
every moment matters yeah I didn't get
any of that from that oh you were
trampled to death now you know how it
feels to be famous every single day
that's right but see that's right single
day she goes do you know you were burnt
alive maybe you know what it's like to
have the burning drive to be a celebrity
she goes sometimes I want to go and die
at a concert but I can't you know what I
do I get on stage while other people die
I get on stage and I perform not always
because I want to because I have
to that's something that I want to see
more of from her it's just never done it
for me but I still think we should go
see the show I would go it's too there's
something too basic about also there's
nostal this Nostalgia porn I don't get
it like all these 35-year-old women
reliving summer camp is this healthy it
would be true Justice if you died at the
ter Swift show it would absolutely be
true Justice if we went and you died
yeah she said I'm glad that my music
ended the life of that fascist no right
right I and by the way if I di her show
handwritten fun please in handwritten f
it is with a a fully functioning and
uncongested
heart that I I hope she goes F [__] said
I was mediocre and he deserved to die
hearing me play My mediocre songs of
which there is one song she's like Taco
Bell there's one thing they've made 30
ways right mhm that's what it is and it
is a testament to the rotten Society we
live in uh that it is the biggest thing
ever I don't know what to tell people
people have that criticism of like they
have they have criticism of like middle
like just the things that most people
eat up like accessible pop culture and
they're like it's cuz everyone's stupid
and I'm a genius that's why I like
[__] Kurt Cobain and you like you
know like no it's just uh it's like a
hamster wheel it's like this is
something that you can just hop on and
I'm not saying I'm a genius and her fans
aren't Geniuses although there might
there's some a little bit of an argument
there but here's what I will say I will
say it's banal go listen to Janice CH go
listen to [__] The Supremes go listen
to Fitzgerald go listen to uh you can
dois Moret better I don't think anybody
nobody's like uh it's just Taylor Swift
for me thanks I don't want anything else
it's like you know but it's it's you're
inundated with it every day it's just
that on every social media job doing
graphic design for the pedophile Island
un have the brochures I'm just meaning
it's it's it's so big that anything
that's so
big there's there's in inevitability
that you get a little tired of like it
being pushed on you I guess I just I we
maybe then I'm letting some other things
bleed into this because it's I you see
this this like uh everyone's going after
Matt R now and now there's articles
about okay but was it was it everyone or
is it like no well now there's articles
and they're always gonna write and now
Marin's got a thing where he's like this
guy [__] sucks and like Marin's
having to comment on the state of Comedy
oh and this guy and it's like did he do
anything other than made a joke yeah no
he didn't do anything wrong well people
aren't mad at the comedy even they're
like it sucks well I honestly I don't
even know his standup at all the [__]
that I've seen that he's done has been
fine it's not like it's not I might do
him I might do something with him yeah
but why why do people hate him so movie
We're trying to like a buddy cop it's me
and him no I'm dead serious well I'm say
I think he's great in a roundabout way
this is kind of like low hanging fruit
because the the the fact that he can
generate all that money is The Testament
that he is like making the hamster wheel
and to go after the hamster wheel is
like that's not it's like uh no but I'm
saying like for example with the with
the Taylor Swift thing MH does she this
woman get hurt if five people in the
world say she's not great no everyone
I've ever met says she's phenomenal by
the way can that all I like to do
occasionally is go wait a minute
remember when everyone said Megan marle
was the hero because she married a
prince and was an act like I'm just
saying God bless Taylor Swift good for
her when there is a paralyzing force of
which everyone agrees it is the greatest
thing ever yeah let there be some people
to go wait a minute what yeah I guess
I'm like that with waterburger or not
water B sorry in- and out in- and out no
you're right everybody loves in- and out
no why I agree with you and it's like I
agree with you so and that and that
sense must say she shouldn't do what she
does or whatever I think it's our
generation as well we're just we it
just I think we were like sort of like
you touch on it before you said about
like Atlantis Mor said right like our
generation like we wanted grunge we
wanted to be little women cutting
themselves I wanted my women
entertainers bleeding on the floor by
the way I saw the Janice the Atlantis
Moret uh play musical horrible jacked
Little Pill was it good oh my God it was
the worst thing I've ever seen it's
terrible dude it's [__] crazy no I
believe Lis Mor now should be executed
it was nuts I believe she should be
executed now it's all of her great songs
and the whole play is just like a girl
gets raped and it's them trying to like
deal with and process this girl getting
raped to Atlantis morette music it's
[__]
crazy you see Marin's going after
everyone he hates everyone the comedian
Compares R to Dan Cook and then
suggested that anti-woke Comics like
Bill Mar have to die sooner the thing
about him is he's just this is just kind
of bitter angry stuff well what I saw is
this was or maybe I brief I briefly saw
this this morning but then it said it
was in some kind of uh like state of
comedy thing which I thought that was
only done a podcast JFL here's what I
like about Mark Mar he's always very
nice to me and I can tell he kind of
hates me but he's always nice to me even
though I think he hates me yeah he's a
nice guy he's like a nice guy even
though I believe he hates me
which by the way I think is nice I guess
I just think that this like going after
like this guy is bizarre it's bizarre
sure yeah I think it's bizarre what did
Matt do he sold tickets he makes people
happy right yeah that's why I don't get
it yeah people about his opening joke in
the same way that the Taylor Swift thing
whenever something gets seismic yeah
what comes with that and it's healthy I
think it's healthy to have some
detractors mhm it's I think it's okay
when something grows to the to the size
of either Matt or whatever Taylor you're
going to have some detractors and
learning to just shrug that off is good
that's actually good otherwise it's a
cult of people that all just go you are
ah dby do you think Taylor Swift is ever
actually on own social media I think
that's good though I think you should
have a cult of people that are like
you're but they have that you're God
they have the biggest cult yeah so
what's wrong with a few detractors
now R doesn't give a [__] about this
article and for who cares magazine I
think we should put Mark Marin in jail
well maybe for other reasons I'd agree I
think we should I think we should
execute Mark Maron for his well I'm if
you want to go down comedy into who we
can execute I mean there's a lot of
peoplebody got a PR anybody's got a
problem with Taylor Swift you're going
to jail yeah I mean that that's coming
yeah I think our path forward is
creating a monoculture where there's one
type that's my only thing one musician
it's tlor Swift it does feel like
we have one pres obsessed with like one
Maryann
Williamson
um I'm reading this I love him and
goes I don't know I don't even
understand what any of this
means I can't see I didn't wear my
glasses here so I can't read any of this
let me read the quote Yeah
if you don't know who he is he's the new
it boy of shitty comedy and he's taken a
big chance in his career right now to
[__] on the mostly female audience that
he accumulated through social media to
sort of kiss up to these pseudo Edge
Lords and personally I don't think it's
going to go well for him and ultimately
my producer Brendon McDonald the genius
made a good point in saying that he
thinks that Matt R is actually
mobilizing a new generation of comics to
push back against what that stands for
much in the way that Dan Cook did to a
different time to once again you know be
creative and bring you energy and voice
to what that doesn't represent when I
tell you I don't know what that means I
genuinely don't know what that means
also I
mean Matt R to
Dan see it the only comparison that
exists is Dane Cook was popular and that
bothered Mark Maron it's not like Dane
Cook was an edge Lord Dan Cook Dane Cook
was a guy that was on stage being like
bees are crazy yeah no he wasn't can you
imagine being stung by bees lugage right
yeah I mean it was [__] harmless so I
I literally show my 10-year-old son Dan
Cook the the tell some people are too
comedy means too much to them the tell
is All In the comparison I think Mark's
a guy where he's very deadly serious
about comedy all the time and it's kind
of like a silly job and it's like do we
really need to be that serious about it
it's a little well it's funny because
it's such like a gen he's like a very
Gen X type of guy right which is like
I'm smart because I got doc Markin
on like I went I went to college pal you
know it's like I but he does does he say
anything that's smart I mean what's is
the context I don't think that's a
that's a fair question does he I don't
know is the context is that is he
supposed to be [__] on things do
they give him subjects to like [__]
rant on because in that case I'll give
him a little bit of I think it's healthy
though here's what I think is healthy
about this I think it's healthy that you
got a guy out there going okay [__] it I
don't like I don't like this that's fine
that's healthy we all of us by the way
have that every day but this is this is
presented as in like we've check in with
the comedy Godfather what is this even
who's what articles it go up go up The
Daily Beast Daily Beast The Daily Beast
and Vox they Vox also and I mean like
right and Huffington Post sure and this
is by Sean L McCarthy the who came to my
show Hall and didn't write about it
thank you that guy stinks yeah so is
that the comic's comic Comics comic I
mean sucks always hated the Comics comic
I mean it's like who cares such a
[__] her
by the way he makes a New York Times guy
that I also have certain issues with
zinaman look like the greatest
journalist of all time the comic's comic
makes Jason zman look like s her he's
one of the most smug guys in the world
he used to show up at shows and he'd be
like well you know I used to be a
comedian yeah he's a [__] he's a [__] he
was on Bobby Kelly's podast I don't
remember what my issue was with him he
wrote some [__] uh about me a while ago
that was kind of shitty and he was just
like kind of condescending and [__]
with it and I'm like dude like just go
[__] yourself you're like Ju Just a
person who's trying to be a comedy
critic like just that's your goal that's
[__] psychotic well also the name is
ridiculous to Brand himself as well I'm
the comedian that all the other
comedians are like this guy's the
[__] best well this is what I mean so
this this this this this is the guy that
wrote the article yeah and now it's
like what
like I mean his his name might as well
be I'm the Best comedian right how he
Brands himself as I'm the I'm the comedy
journalist known as the Best comedian
yeah I've decided to do journalism
instead I'm the greatest comedian yeah
I'm the one I'm I'm the Comics comic
yeah yeah I think
that's he was like a step above Patrick
from the stand in his old Vlog like
that's like I think it's a step below
Patrick maybe honest Patrick was great
Patrick just like comedy Patrick liked
comedy no Patrick's but I'm just saying
like in terms of how to take it
seriously as German this whole new thing
where everything's got to a beef is
stupid oh I hate it Comics are not
beefing with each other like that it's
not rap it's none of that no one cares
everybody's old now everyone's old
everyone's 40 people are like going to
the doctor like yeah I'm not still yeah
you're still not I need I need to like
that's the thing
nobody's in the streets like that that's
the reality yeah people just don't like
each Anthony jck doesn't like me because
I did that thing about when he went
after you guys I defended you you guys
he doesn't like me that's fine no one
cares yeah no one cares you're not
supposed to like everybody we're not
supposed to be friends with every person
we know if you like if you're a person
that you like everybody you're a liar
you're just a phony you're you're not a
real person so the reality I respect
that Marin doesn't give a [__] and
whatever he's right or wrong about it's
just like you need a cantankerous guy to
when something new comes along to go
[__] that you need that guy yeah now you
don't have to be that guy but some
somebody's got to do that somebody's got
to do that you know I don't think it's
that's necessary you don't think it's
necessary no why well that's sort of a
contradiction if like people aren't
beefing that I mean it's literally well
here's the thing it's not this isn't
even a beef yeah this is an old comic
who's gets hates everything and
everybody that's the thing he's been
doing for 30 years so he's just doing
his bit then he what a hot guy comes and
goes I'm filling theaters with women and
this guy's going to go yay no
his whole well he doesn't have to go yay
but it's like
it's thing the state of the industry
address at JFL for years his whole point
was that this entire industry sucks and
everyone in and sucks and every decision
everyone makes is wrong so that's his
that's been his thing forever yeah
that's why that's why I don't find it
like inconsistent I just as a when I
started in comedy in a weird way this is
just the way that I've always thought of
it it's like there's us and them and I
kind of root for Comics you kind of see
somebody like uh Matt r i i watch you
blow up I watch Shane blow up I watched
Andrew Schultz blow up you're like oh
[__] dude like the like this is like
good for comedy overall it's all good
for comedy exactly because it'll lead
the ticket sales for other it's all good
for even if you're nothing like him
especially 100% that's it sort of how it
always was like like I didn't really
understand the whole comedy beef thing
it was like when I started in comedy it
was like everybody came from a different
different background you had college
graduates you had homeless people you
had old ladies you had [__] you had
all these different types of people and
we all just came to do the same thing
and it was just about just getting funny
and um yeah when I watch somebody like
Matt rif BL up even if I didn't like I
don't know his comedy well enough to
have a real opinion on it but even if I
didn't like it I'd go [__] it dude good
for him he's [__] killing it selling
out massive massive there's not one
ounce of me that has any negative things
to say about anyone blowing up really
yeah you know I think it's funny when
you are a comedian your job is to kind
of make fun of culture so Lewis you
brought this up when a comedian gets so
so famous that they become part of
culture yeah it's like when Amy became
just a celebrity Pete Davidson yeah I
love Pete he's such a sweet kid when
everyone like part of my thing is
everyone I know you are you still
friends with
Amy uh I don't think we were ever
friends oh really we've texted yeah
we've texted with the Israel stuff I'm
like good for you I like cuz here's my
point not not necessarily what
everything she's saying I will say that
if you have that amount of
money and do whatever you want say
whatever you want go out there and say
whatever you want if if if that doesn't
buy
you the like opportunity to piss
everyone off or a lot of people off
what's the point of it you know and I
did think that she was like going on
lighting stuff on fire and I thought
that
was kind of good as a comic I was like
good for you it didn't seem like she'd
been cautious and calculated with that
stuff now it doesn't mean she was
correct but it did feel like she was
like hey I'm just yeah I think we should
kill them all if you have F like
tweeting she like twe like kill them all
like well if you have [__] you money and
you don't say [__] you once in a while
that's crazy Rogan when they came after
Rogan with that nword uh compilation
that's a different story because here's
the deal he's not a guy that he doesn't
I don't think he thinks why people
should go around willy-nilly using that
word willy-nilly yeah willy-nilly
himself black gu willy-nilly is okay to
use it I use whatever word I want don't
think you should be calling Wily nilly
that I don't think Joe is I don't think
Jo call willy nilly the N word yeah Joe
was um I think Joe was literally going I
regret using that word act like real
realistically yeah I don't think he was
like I have to fold for yeah Spotify mhm
I I think he looked back on it and was
like uh he's got kids he's got daughter
you know what I mean I don't think I
don't think he wants them saying that
joke about Planet of the Apes
[Laughter]
although I don't I don't think I watched
the clip when it came out I I saw I saw
the headline I was like I've heard the
n-word
before I have as well yeah I don't know
I've been to gas digital
been to the gas digital now I've already
heard the nword I don't know what are we
promoting gentlemen here on the uh at
the end of this we've solv so many
problems in comedy uh I guess yeah I
just I've I've seen I feel like I've
just caused more problems for myself
well I'm getting three lawsuits yeah
Brock Pierce uh uh ey analyst ey analyst
rough note to start off with
yeah well I mean listen it gives context
to Puerto Rico yeah
I love by the way that is the thing
about white people it's just your Island
will be colonized by white pedophiles no
matter what you do right like you're
coming now or later yeah Nick Mullen the
special is out on the Adam Friedland
Show YouTube Adam freedland show this
come out tomorrow oh yeah so Sunday with
Abby Martin we're dropping two episodes
this and Abby Martin Abby Martin take a
look at that one Sunday is the premiere
to be on the Adam freand show channel if
you haven't watched the Adam freand show
please check it out um our last one was
with Dave poroy from bar stool uh but
yeah Premier Sunday we might do like a
live stream Premiere thing there's like
a YouTube Premiere so we might get all
the cameras going in the studio and have
a party Lis J Gomez is the proprietor
and CEO of the gas digital Network on
the gas digital Network you'll find
shows like Legion of skanks the real ass
podcast part of the problem with Dave
Smith and many others Lewis
ofc. that is the website new tour coming
up is where you can find his new tour
where he'll be going to Lisbon Portugal
with 15 people and then wondering why he
has not turned a profit he'll be playing
a cafe there check out my half hour that
I just put out on my YouTube channel I
have my first special up there as well L
Shay Gomez presents Louis Shay Gomez and
uh yeah the meaty ogre tour coming to a
city near you I want to come on a few
dates of that to just jump on it just
for fun I would love you because we
enjoy you we talked about you on Matt
and Shane good I heard you guys said all
good things it's always amazing things
but we talked about how at the beginning
of gas digital you would have the these
meetings in Ralph's house and you'll be
you'd be like you'll be like now Brenda
is our new ad person and it would just
be like a [__] woman from Staten
Island with a shopping bag and she'd
have like one eye would' be like
wandering and you'd be like Brenda
what's going on with the ads and she'd
be like the ads St at and you'd be like
good good but no we said amazing things
all right I love both of you always
great to see you thank you for coming on
and we'll see you soon love you thank
you